(BIRDS CHIRPING) MALE SPEAKER: THE TODAY
SHOW IS INTERESTED IN SOME OF THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT JANE AND TABER ARE WORKING ON.
JANE, OF COURSE, A BIOSPHERIAN.
AND TABER, A BIOSPHERIAN, TOO.
THEY WERE IN WITH A TWO-YEAR GROUP.
UH, JANE AND TABER HAVE A COMPANY
THAT THEY'VE CREATED IN TUCSON
WHICH TO ME IS AN INCREDIBLE TECHNOLOGY.
THEY WANT TO BRING IN PEOPLE TO
A HUNDRED THOUSAND FEET ELEVATION
ON A BALLOON INSIDE OF A CAPSULE.
AND THEN DROP THE CAPSULE ON A GLIDER SO
THAT THEY CAN SEE THE EARTH FOR A BIT.
MALE SPEAKER: IT WAS REALLY A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THEM TO USE THE BACKDROP OF BIOSPHERE 2
TO EXPLAIN AND TALK ABOUT THEIR
ORIGINAL INTENTS WITH THIS FACILITY;
HOW ONE OF ITS KEY POINTS WAS
BETTER UNDERSTANDING AIR SYSTEMS
FOR POTENTIAL SPACE TRAVEL.
BUT ALSO TO HAVE THE FOLKS WITH THE TODAY
SHOW -- YOU KNOW, A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED,
SYNDICATED SHOW -- UH, FEATURING
THEIR NEW COMPANY WORLD VIEW;
BUT ALSO FEATURING BIOSPHERE 2.
MALE SPEAKER: WELL, IF YOU LOOK AT
THE COLLEGE OF SCIENCE IN GENERAL,
IT HAS RESEARCH THAT IS JUST UNIQUE
AND INCREDIBLE, FROM THE TREE RING LAB,
WHICH WE INVENTED, TO THE MIRROR LAB, WHICH
IS AMAZING, TO THE LARGE BINOCULAR TELESCOPE,
WHICH IS THE BIGGEST TELESCOPE AROUND.
AND THE BIOSPHERE JUST FITS THAT KIND
OF RESEARCH BEING THE BIGGEST APPARATUS
IN THE WORLD THAT CAN DO ENVIRONMENTAL RESEARCH.
MALE SPEAKER: MOST OF THE LABORATORY
OR FIELD SITES THAT THE FACULTY
AT THE UNIVERSITY ARE INVOLVED WITH OR
WORKING IN ARE NOT OPEN TO THE PUBLIC.
BUT, WE'RE OPEN EVERY DAY, WHERE THE
FOLKS CAN COME THROUGH AND LEARN,
OBVIOUSLY A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE HISTORY.
BUT, THEY'LL LEARN ABOUT THE SCIENCE
THAT WE'RE DOING AND HOW IT'S INTEGRATED
AND HOW IT AFFECTS THEIR EVERYDAY LIFE.
MALE SPEAKER: ALL OUR RESEARCH HAS TO
DO WITH INTERDISCIPLINARY RESEARCH,
GRANT CHALLENGES IN SCIENCE
THAT DEAL WITH THE ENVIRONMENT.
WE -- WE NEVER SETTLE IN
THE KIND OF RESEARCH WE DO.
AND FURTHERMORE, IT ALLOWS
FOR THE INTERDISCIPLINARITY
THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF ARIZONA
IS SO WELL KNOWN FOR.